i am so excited to talk to our next
guest that i'm freaking out okay so he
has a whopping 138 acting credits on his
imdb page including hits like oh
jurassic park
independence day
one of my very favorites the big chill
oh let's not forget about the fly
and season two of his show the world
according to jeff goldblum just dropped
on disney plus please welcome the real
jeff goldblum
[Applause]
i would be well i've waited to talk to
you about this for probably
i don't know almost 40 years
um
what could this be okay really so i was
like eight and i got together with my
girlfriend and we choreographed like a
dance number
for my mom through a party at our house
jade yes exactly yeah yeah and you came
over to the party but i remember my
girlfriend and i like coming out with
like a little boombox and you know we
were doing movies back then so i don't
know why this like shyness
or embarrassment i guess because i guess
i just i don't know i mean we were in
movies like why so i repress tape and we
did like this whole dance and we were
like choreographing it and like you know
doing it
and
and then we finished it and then we just
were like
fantastic
well somehow now i don't think twice
about doing that in front of you but i
guess i was still coming into my own at
eight and i was like oh my god jeff
goldblum like i was so obsessed with you
and i was like he saw me do the dance
and by the way we practiced it but you
would have never known watching us we
both look like marty feldman like and
hula hoop it's so funny you should say
that i just showed the kids uh young
frankenstein marty feldman
my absolute icon
um so yeah and i just every time i think
of you i think of your magnanimous body
of work and that we love you and know
you and then i also i'm like
and i bit it on my choreograph dance
when i was eight years old in front of
you i remember
also going to see the fly in times
square
which was
if you want to have a baller
audience moment go see the fly in the
80s in times square when it was open oh
my god i snuck in the back of it and i
know what you're talking about it was a
very raucous and fun you know time that
was this is what you want when you go to
the movies it was i mean did you like
did you know that that film was going to
be as incredible
as it was there was nothing like it and
it was just so bone chilling and
interesting and
i mean i just i loved that movie so much
thank you you're so sweet
now will you talk to me about the world
according to jeff goldblum that just
dropped season two on disney plus i've
seen a whole bunch of it i'm really i
was watching you dance with the seal i
have to say is this not such an
interesting dream job as in to explore
your curiosities
yeah it is a it is a dream job like that
i'm a curious uh character the people at
uh utopia jane rood and all the
producers and and um not geo they're
very good and so they research things
and prepare me and i get a little
prepared i'm not if not conscientious
but i say you know let me actually on
camera be caught
meeting them actually and we're not
going to pretend anything and let me
learn so so i know a little bit about it
but um so it's all surprising and they
they they like to surprise me so i did
things in the dog episode for instance
oh that's funny
so yeah all that i just walk into it and
i go what is this what's happening and
then there'll be puppies there and they
smother me that's not you know planned
or anything so and look at this this is
during the dance episode and that's at a
roller rink at uh in atlanta and she's
teaching me you know how to
get up up and uh running on roller
skates this is from fireworks that's
souza the souzas are one of these
families who do the big uh things which
i didn't know about
[Applause]
it's storytelling and it's shining
spotlight on
people and what they're doing i can't i
have to ask okay so my daughter frankie
her favorite film her two favorite films
is titan well three jaws jurassic park
and titanic and so we watch jurassic
park all the time frankie how old is she
she's seven
oh my gosh and you have boys i have a
six-year-old charlie
ocean and a four-year-old river joe yeah
i have frankie seven in all of nine so
frankie and i watch jurassic park all
the time and um well first of all
there's that picture of you that became
so famous did you ever know that you'd
like be thirst trapping everybody all
these years hello
literally
that photo is so
famous
there is straight up
merch with that photo but i need to ask
you about jurassic world dominion which
is coming out next year you guys have
already shot it and it's original cast
laura dern sam neal yeah and how quinn
how happened
dallas howard we at the beginning of the
year i love bryce dallas howard i love
bryce dallas love her yes but there are
more people into dewanda wise and bd
wong oh i love bd1 he's in all of them
yes and daniela pineda and justice smith
and omar sai and mamadou aceh
and dieshan lochman it's a big cast
colin trevaro did this one very excited
i am about it i think it's going to be
something we all
have nice things to do in it
um we shot it in england at pinewood
studios yes of course famous pinewood
studios
lots of lots of epic films james bond
i feel like i have i'm losing track i
know i've stopped counting the latest
one is going to be so epic well i think
it's going to be good yeah yeah we and
i'll bet you know i've been shy about
showing the kids screen time at all and
anything that could scare them although
i showed them jurassic park just a
little bit ago and but they haven't
really been to the movie theaters at all
but i told them when it comes out next
summer i'll bet it's going to be loud
and big but i'll bet they might like it
let's bring back times square in the 80s
[Music]
you